he was the richest man in America the
world at his fingertips and yet he was a
prisoner to his own dark fears his
achievements were astounding
he created the fastest plane on the
planet was the driving force behind the
largest aircraft ever built and was a
pioneer in filmmaking and yet he is
remembered for the eccentricities that
drove him from hero to hermit in his
heyday he was a romantic figure with
movie starlets fucking to be seen on his
arm and yet he spent the last 26 years
of his life as a recluse obsessed with
cleanliness and controlling every aspect
of his environment
even as he sunk deeper and deeper into
madness in this Bala graphics episode we
enter these strange world of the
original eccentric billionaire Howard
Hughes
when it comes to the life of Howard
Robert Hughes it can be a challenge to
separate fact from fiction even the
details of his birth were falsified
official records give that date as
December the 24th 1905 in Houston Texas
the reality is that had been born two
months earlier in the oil town of Humble
a hundred miles from Texas from there
the Bligh's well they just built upon
each other he was not one of triplets
nor was his mother's sister's
illegitimate son or a substitute baby
brought in to replace the one who had
died all these fanciful stories were
later told by the man himself in order
to build upon the aura that surrounded
his name hew senior known as boh a
shortened form of his middle name
Robards had been a penniless scoundrel
bumming his way around Joplin Missouri
at the turn of the 19th century in 1899
he was run out of the town by the
furious father of a girl who he tried to
seduce with no other options the
dreamy-eyed larrikin decided to try his
hand at the oil business making his way
to texas bo just happened to be on hands
when a thousand-foot spume of black oil
hurtled itself from the ground at
Spindletop On January the 10th 1901 he
was among the first to grab claims of
buying our plans for a few dollars an
acre and selling it only days later
hundreds of dollars within a few months
having an asked a small fortune boom
moved to Houston where he founded the
Texas oil fuel company the forerunner to
Texaco within six months he had also
married be darkly pretty but seriously
hypochondriacal alene gone Oh
aleem she was terrified of small animals
and had an insect phobia fueled by an
obsession with cleanliness these traits
well they were to find full expression
in her only son by the time that Howard
Jr known as Sonny entered the world in
1905 his father was still chasing oil
still he was frustrated not so much at
finding the oil locations but at the
inferior quality of the drilling tools
that were available finally out of
exasperation he set his sights on
designing a better drill this on
November the 20th 1908 he emerged from
his study with designs for a bit that
contained
168 cutting edges he had just invented
the hughes tool bits from which would
flow the millions of dollars which would
both enrich and ultimately destroy his
son and heir by the age of four it was
obvious that Sonny Hughes had inherited
the partial deafness that ran in the
family the condition it would become
progressively worse over howard's
lifetime as a youngster it caused him to
become isolated and introspective now
that money was no object the
eight-year-old Hughes was sent to an
exclusive private school he didn't make
a very good impression though with a
head teacher remembering him as an
uppity at snobbish boy who refused to
join in with the other boys preferring
to sit with the girls not surprisingly
he soon gained a reputation as a sissy
but the young hue see also gains a
reputation as a technical whiz kid he
put together his first wireless radio
transmitter when he was only 11 years
old a year later his picture appeared in
the local newspaper proudly standing
next to the first motorized bicycle in
Houston which he had put together from a
steam engine in an effort to get his
nervous and timid boy to man up Bo
decided to pack him off to boot camp
over the day which was the Boy Scouts so
during the 1916 summer recess Sonny
found himself in the middle of the pokop
Mountains in Pike County Pennsylvania he
was under the tutelage of a grizzled old
timer by the name of General Dan beard
surprisingly the young Hughes he took to
the woodsman life like the proverbial
duck to water it was already quite first
and quickly learned to whistle defects
Indian signs and simulate bird calls he
seemed to excel under the military
discipline of the camp to away from the
overprotective gaze of his mother it
seemed he was able to shake off his
effeminate nature and show his true
colors in the fall of 1920 a 14-year old
Sonny went with his father to the
harvard-yale rowing crew races in
Connecticut Hughes senior promised to
buy his son whatever he wanted if his
favorite Harvard won the race when
Harvard
smashed Yale by 14 seconds the boy held
out his hands in expectation and asked
for $5.00 he then pointed to a sign
further up the river
advertising rides on a Curtiss flying
boat for $5.00 you see me reluctantly
joined his son for the 10-minute flight
it made the father sick but the son had
just discovered the one true love of his
life he found the experience of flying
both exhilarating and liberating from
that moment on he would be at his most
peaceful when he was alone in an
airplane flying high above a world that
he's so often tried to escape by the age
of 19 both of his parents were debt his
mother had died suddenly when he was 16
after suffering complications from an
ectopic pregnancy beau died less than
two years later of a heart attack
leaving Hughes Junior the heir to the
Hughes Tool Company he dropped out of
college to take control of the company
quickly discovering that he knew nothing
about the oil business
he soon hired a self-taught accountants
by the name of Noah Dietrich to take the
controls at the same time he was legally
declared himself an adult and seized
full control of the entire family
fortune
Hughes now had the money that he needed
to pursue his greatest passions those
passions
well they had nothing to do with oil
instead they revolved around building
and flying airplanes and also making
movies in Hollywood and other of his
passions was actually Dolph well one day
while playing at the Beverly Hills
Country Club that he watched his a
biplane flew overhead and tipped his
wing attendant Howard was able to track
down the fly Ahrens offered to pay him
the outrageous sum of $800 per day if he
would teach him to fly the pilots
wealthy readily agreed in two years
later Hughes was issued his private
pilot's license
as lighters chronic shyness Howard was
fascinated with the glitz and glamour of
Hollywood in order to break into the
business
he signed talented director Lewis
milestone to a three-year contract the
pairing they immediately struck gold
with their debut picture two Arabian
Nights claiming an Academy Award in 1927
this gave used the confidence to take on
his next challenge a fusion of his two
great loves flying and movies failing to
find a director who shared his passion
for the skies Howard decided to go it
alone writing producing and directing
the world's first true aviation picture
it was called Hell's Angels this was
going to be his magnum opus and he was
prepared to pour in as much money time
and effort as was needed to create this
masterpiece an air fleet was contracted
that was bigger than that of some
countries during aerial filming
sequences Howard's obsessive compulsion
led him to fixate on such things as
cloud formations he would scrap a
valuable minutes of perfectly good
footage forcing his pilots to reshoot
until the clouds were just right
one day accused in an effort to control
every aspect of an aerial shoot he went
up in a small Scout plane but no sooner
area centered when the plane went into a
tailspin and crashed into the ground
Howard managed to walk away uninjured
the first of a number of miraculous
plane crash escapes a bemused stuntman
actually commented that at least he
hasn't injured his check-writing
arm so Howard's obsession with
perfection meant that the shooting
schedule for Hells Angels gots hook to
the out of control in the meantime the
public had become infatuated with the
latest Hollywood innovation talkies
against everyone's advice he has decided
to Reese crip to the movie and reshoot
all of the dialogue scenes this time
adding sound the reshoot proved to be
the break of a lifetime for a former
bits player named Holly and carpenter
the leading lady of the movie Drita
Neeson was caught because of their
strong Norwegian accent and carpenters
stepped into the role Hughes transformed
her into Jean Harlow the platinum blonde
bombshell he became a sensation during
the 1930s Hells Angels it was a
box-office smash returning double its
production cost of four million dollars
which was an exorbitant amount at that
time unfortunately for Hughes three
movie flops followed that he managed to
cash in on the public's obsession with
Al Capone by producing the movie
Scarface we've actually got a biographic
sideo on him as well you can find it in
a link in the description below all
right so here's was one of these guys he
always wanted to push the boundaries and
he films this movie with all of the
violence and all of the obscenities that
you'd imagine would be associated
without her pain
and not surprisingly the sensors knocks
it back
demanding major edits to the movie Alex
to their surprise Hughes sued them and
he won the ravine would be released just
as Hughes that intended this is the
story of Scarface Tony come on Tony his
lust for power for fancy women so after
the release of Scarface Hughes decided
to step back from Hollywood to indulge
in his other great passion and that of
course was flying
in 1934 he easily won a flying race in
Miami the success fueled his ambitions
inspiring him to set up the Hughes
Aircraft Company he now set out to
design and build the world's fastest
racing plane the results of all of his
efforts was the h1 which used flew to a
new world speed record of 352 miles per
hour on August the 18th 1935 by 1938
Hughes was intent on achieving another
world first the fastest flight around
the world in a modified Lockheed 14 he
took to the skies with a hand-picked
crew and set off from New York
16 hours Sam's 38 minutes later they
landed in Paris then on to Moscow and
then on to Siberia three days 19 hours
and 14 minutes after setting out they
were back in New York juice he was
hailed as a conquering hero and for
three days the painfully shy adventurer
endured ticker tape parades and
receptions in New York Chicago
Washington and Houston in 1940 Hughes
moved into commercial aviation by
grabbing a controlling share of
Transworld airlines or TWA a short time
later the US government came calling
they wanted Hughes Aircraft to supply
plane parts artillery shells and cannon
barrels helped support the war effort in
Europe ten years later with America well
and truly immersed in the conflict
Hughes was contracted to design and
build a massive flying boat in order to
overcome the German u-boat menace that
was causing serious problems for us
transport vessels so while doing the
testing and design for these projects
Hughes was involved in his fourth plane
crash he was testing a Sikorsky s 43 and
phibian aircraft on Lake Mead Nevada the
plane they went down into the frigid
waters naturally killed a CAA inspector
and an engineer who were also on board
the vessel Hughes he once again managed
to walk away although he did receive a
large gash to the top of his
it was around this time that hues began
to exhibit patterns of behavior that
seems odd to you on Lucas
compulsive hands washing to avoid germs
checking and rechecking his work and
always seeking symmetry constantly
trying to make things perfect all
classic signs of OCD were seen as
symptoms of a deteriorating mind this
was hardly a good time for whispers and
sanity with his business empire rapidly
expanding in his business contracts
imposing waited months Hughes was facing
stresses and pressures from all
directions to huge contracts for the
xf11 reconnaissance plane and the HK one
Spruce Goose were both over-budget and
they were overdue most of the delays
they were due to Hughes's incessant
tinkering and his insistence on being
the test pilot for both planes and well
there was this insistence which brought
about his closest call yet on July the
7th 1946 Hughes took the xf11 for its
first ever test flight over the los
angeles basin now for the first 45
minutes this plane functioned perfectly
then suddenly a propeller malfunction
caused the plane to plummet to the
ground desperately wrestling with the
controls Hughes hoped to land on a
fairway at the Los Angeles Country Club
instead he plunged through the roof of a
nearby house this it was one crash that
Hughes he wasn't able to walk away from
he was extracted from the wreckage as he
went up in flames and rushed to the
hospital after ripping the corner from
two homes in Beverly Hills California
the plane finally plunged into this
house the force of the impact virtually
wrecked the building and caused the
plane to catch fire he suffered severe
head trauma and multiple burns along
with fractures to his neck these
injuries they were going to cause him
suffering for the rest of his life do
you control his pain Hughes started
taking a lot of drugs he relied on a
three-part cocktail of them codeine
valium and emperess these are drugs that
he took daily for the next 30 years
still the pain and head injuries they
affected his behavior causing his OCD
to spin out of control long before his
addiction to painkillers Howard Hughes
well he had another addiction and that
was two women when he came to
Hollywood's in 1925 near a wife and an
enormous sexual appetite
the wife Ella soon tired of his
infidelities filing for divorce in 1929
the sexual appetite very well it remains
and was satisfied with a list of
Hollywood conquests that would include
such stars as Jean Peters Rita Hayworth
David Gardner Lana Turner and Katharine
Hepburn Hughes well he was obsessed with
the female form and this was actually
the inspiration for his most
controversial film The Outlaw said
during the Old West the movie was a
showcase for the voluptuous Jane Russell
with Hughes personally ensuring that her
dresses were cut low enough to
accentuate her size 38 deep bust once
again these centers were outraged but
Hughes whelmed he was laughing all the
way to the bank 5 in the 1940s Hughes's
health issues were impacting upon his
increasingly complicated business empire
in addition to his ownership of TWA and
Hughes Tool Company he now also owned
the RKO movie studio at the same time he
was building a huge aerospace company to
develop spy technology for the military
in 1947 the pressure on Hughes was
ramped up several notches when he was
subpoenaed to appear before Congress
regarding alleged improprieties in his
government contracts in a commanding
performance with the TV cameras rolling
he strongly denied profiteering from the
war effort
my reputation walled up in it and I have
stated several times that if it's a
failure of this country I'd never come
back it is sort of ironic that this
congressional appearance is most
confident strong and dominant public
outing was also the last time that the
public would see Howard Hughes the
brilliant fearless visible millionaire
well he was transforming into a
mysterious invisible
you
the 53 year old used was now completely
intent on retrieving from society the
symptoms of his undiagnosed obsessive
compulsive disorder were by now all too
apparent he refused to shake hands or
touch door handles instructions to his
aides were repeated in meticulous detail
and he flew into violent rages when
things were not exactly as he had
commanded those who worked for Hughes
began calling him the old man and they
became seriously concerns that he was
going insane the FBI who are actually
keeping tabs on him noted in 1957 that
he was acting like a screwball paranoiac
they added that he could even be capable
of murder then seemingly totally out of
the blue Hughes declared that he was
going to marry one of the many starlets
that he had been seeing Jean Peters many
people believe that Hughes decided to
get hitched so that his aides would no
longer be able to have him committed to
an asylum less than a year after
marrying Peters in a Nevada motel room
Hughes descended into one of the most
bizarre episodes of his life he told his
aides that he wanted to view some movies
at a studio on Sunset Boulevard
he didn't leave that darkened screening
room for more than four months with his
right hand and hold the bag out to me at
a 45-degree angle so I may reach into
the bag without without touching the
paper
during this time his diet consisted of
chocolate bars and milk and he spent his
days and nights sitting and naked in a
chair staring at the screen during this
time she was communicated with his aides
by scribbling on a yellow legal pad
instructions included not looking at him
and not speaking to him unless spoken to
first over those four months at the
studio his personal hygiene it rapidly
deteriorated even as his germ obsession
intensified when he finally emerged from
the screening room in the spring of 1958
Hughes was an unkempt ragged and
pathetic mess following this he pretty
much immediately checked into the
Beverly Hills Hotel another place you're
only supposed to stay on a temporary
basis but Hughes ended up staying in
there for years here he reverted to his
screening room habits sitting naked in
the dark hour after hour business
dealings were conducted by telephone and
through his handwritten instructions
during this time his drug use also
escalated as he fought continuous pain
now injecting himself with morphine to
supplement his mega doses of codeine and
Valium in 1966 conducting negotiations
completely by telephone
Hughes sold his controlling share in TWA
this made him a billionaire and the
richest man in America but rather than
simply sit on his fortune Hughes despite
his pathetic physical condition set his
sights on conquering a brand-new
frontier and that frontier what it would
be Las Vegas
his first move was to relocate to the
penthouse suite of the Desert Inn where
he could continue his bizarre lifestyle
without interruption he then began
buying up the city starting with the
very hotel that he was living in his
investments included a local TV station
which he bought so that he could demand
they play the movies that he wanted to
watch now by 1970 Hughes he was a
prisoner of his own design and then as
if things weren't crazy enough already
he suddenly left the Desert Inn without
warning many in his entourage they
thought that he'd been abducted but
three weeks later he turns up in the
Bahamas from there he announced that he
was turning the day-to-day operations of
his empire over to a group of Mormon
aides in 1972 Hughes relocated to a
hotel room in London he left the room
only once to go flying but this was like
no flight he had ever taken before
climbing into the cockpit he took off
all of his clothes and flew around
London in the nude following what would
be his final flight of the helm Hughes
his condition well it rapidly
deteriorated he took a fall in his
London hotel room which increased his
reliance on painkillers and
unfortunately took away his ability to
walk
things well they only went downhill from
here
as if by design uses last hours were
spent in the app he was traveling to
Houston to receive medical treatments
his emancipated body finally breathed
its last breath on April the 5th 1976
the world's it was shocked when the
autopsy pictures revealed the terrible
condition of his body the results of
undiagnosed OCD multiple severe head
injuries and 30 years of largely
self-imposed neglect it was a sad end
for a truly brilliant man so I hope you
enjoyed that video about Howard Hughes
if you did do give us a thumbs up below
and don't forget to subscribe we put out
two new biographies of people like this
every week so click that subscribe
button and also if you'd like to check
out some other videos by us you can find
them linked to in the description below
and as always thanks for watching